what's going on man welcome Steve Steve
Aoki's here Yeah right there it's not
your book this morning oh they just gave
they didn't give us a chance to read it
we came in and was on the show we had a
chance to read your book welcome in Jim
was just saying that the book smells
really good
yes the first thing I do is smell a new
book yeah like a book why'd you call it
blue well it's uh it's my favorite color
it's also my last name Wilkie Aoki means
blue tree no and it's a good way to like
have an overarching theme with this book
book because there's there's so many
different shades of blue and so many
different kind of like the processes of
Who I am kind of I go through the whole
thing from the beginning to I would say
not even in the last five years it's
more like the the beginnings and a lot
of the failure a lot of like the you
know I don't know just kind of an
emotional roller coaster
did you fail a lot yeah we were like I
mean in the beginning you were kind of
just a party promoter more than a than a
performer right right yeah I mean well
in the beginning I was in I was in bands
right yeah so I went from being in bands
to starting my label to support to like
find in and support young bands and then
and then I eventually was throwing
parties in support of the label and then
I was you know that's where the party
promoting came in because I had to bring
people into these rooms and then I was
the DJ when I didn't know how to DJ cuz
I was like I didn't I couldn't hire
anyone because I'd have the money so
you're just like and yeah but we need a
DJ I'll just do it cuz I'm here exactly
I'll open the doors right and and then
I'll have like you know at the time this
is like in the 2000s so and the kind of
music that did mock my record label was
putting out was was indie rock it's like
block party we put out there
first you know EPS and then did the the
album with Vice and then put out the
kills it's a lot of like rock and indie
so like we'd have friends come in deejay
like the AES or Interpol or you know
Mars Volta or the shins or whoever it
was in town and then I would start the
party and then we have our own little
scene in LA and that that was a does a
very interesting time because it's all
pre social media and and there was like
this convergence of all these really
interesting cultures like it was like
the indie scene but then it was also
fusing when in with like when Lady Gaga
first started and she was coming to like
perform at our small little parties and
Kid Cudi was coming through and I was
you know so we had like will.i.am and
Kate Cuddy and black eye peas and the
start of LMFAO and the start of Skrillex
and it's like when did it start at what
point did you start to go more into the
dance and party world because it seems
like those artists are way more dance
music than indie rock so the thing it's
like there was this fusion of indie and
electronic music and LCD Soundsystem was
was a big inspiration around that time
Daft Punk mm-hmm
this was all like in the late probably
late 2000s when DJing started becoming
more of a thing where it wasn't just
about going to the club and you didn't
know where the DJ was you know right
right it was just like a guy who played
them yes quietly in the back yeah yeah
cause like you think of a DJ back then
it was like you don't think of them you
well why didn't he chase like what do
you think about right Mitzvahs like oh
yeah yeah like that's where you make the
real money do you think those guys are
good though a lot of the wedding DJs or
a lot of them not good what do you guys
are amazing yeah they're really good
they're really good why do you say that
because they they know like they look at
the crowd they really are DJing they're
like okay we got we got the all the 40s
the 50s the 60s we got all like play to
them we got to get them off their you
know off their chairs and have them
dancing you know it is true it gets like
weddings are the spots where you're
gonna have like that sort of varied
audience like if you're at a club you
one client out for the most one age
group yeah I write that you're like this
is the music that I'm gonna play for
them but when you're looking around a
room and you're like I have to appeal to
there's some kids over there teenagers
you know every age group you can imagine
I mean there's definitely some dated
wedding DJ you know wedding DJs and and
bar mitzvah deejay is that just like I'm
like you know we the young guys the
young kids are like you got to play you
know post Malone to so if they can pay
post Malone and Abba briny they're
pretty good yeah I did you get to the we
have a DJ friend who's very good he does
like local weddings he works here but
it's you to get to that next level where
all of a sudden you're you're a little
bit more know every DJ a celebrity DJ
say what do you have to do like what's
the difference between someone who just
does weddings and then you go to that
next level where everybody knows who you
are like how do you go from Dennis
Falcone who's our wedding DJ friend
Yahoo Steve Aoki mm-hmm well so I mean
I'd say the the the number one way to
actually have your own audience and not
just be a wedding DJ is you get in the
studio you have to learn how to make
music you know I mean at the end of the
day it's like the same reason why you
would go see the killers or the why you
would go see a band or a rapper or a
country singer or whatever right you're
gonna go see them because you want to
hear them play their songs right so it's
the same kind of concept I mean you know
even for me like when when I when I was
in bands like you know it's like if you
could be in a cover band or you could be
playing your own music and if you take
the risk of playing on music and no one
likes it then you're probably gonna
start in a new band part of the wedding
to play your own music to they all want
to hear covers yeah
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah if you if you're in the studio
that's why these there's so many young
DJ's that are that are very famous
because you know like this culture now
starts at a very young age I mean you
could start producing it when you're 11
right it's like a video game it's like
instead of playing fortnight and you can
get your son or your daughter to be like
don't play fortnight here's this video
game esque kind of thing where it's a
doll and you're like look at all the
colors and you can learn how to like
here's what notes do here's what this
does and and they start making music and
they treat it like a video game right by
the time 14 they're like you know like
if everyone's playing their music
they're like who's this 14 year old kid
that's that everyone's playing this from
the middle of Arkansas you know I don't
hear our music and colors are any weird
stuff like that dude because like some
like Darrell Hammond does impressions
but he hears voices in color right I've
heard there's a weird way of like kind
of sectioning off sounds he hears you
don't hear it any I wish I did
pardon my ignorance on DJing is there
still a thing with scratching records is
that something like what's nice for you
like you should think about DJing cuz
you wouldn't actually need to bring the
record you can make the sound of I also
do the jet vehicle the Jetsons but how
would it sound like at the Jetsons
vehicle all of a sudden a record scribe
if you want a high Rhodes yo list I'm
not saying that's great but I'm saying
something it's something turntablist
culture is strong you know yeah I mean
there's so many from world just like in
any music genre there's so many
different subgenres of I mean there's a
turntablist like the technical world of
scratching that
was so super talented and and like this
DJ from New York a track he has his own
he has an award ceremony that that
celebrates a lot of turntable as DJs so
there's a world for that there's like
the EDM world that that you see like the
festivals where DJ is rocking in you
know 10,000 50,000 people whatever it
might be and it's playing that pure
electronic sound there's hip-hop DJ's
there's so many different kinds of DJs
just like anything else our friend is it
let's break down this in then it should
be part of the compilation
oh this is right outside bring let's
bring Dennis in but also a lot of yeah
we have a lot of DJ's here Troy is in
how do you what do you can see I don't
wanna see your band what do you consider
it it's like a DJ production do we
actually just put out two songs on demo
a yeah it's cool so been a big fan of
the label and big fan of Steve for many
years I like DJ Tanner from full house
I've never met Steve but I've yeah I
know people that he knows very well so
yeah definitely you have to learn
electronic music then like as you're
DJing and you're like oh this is
becoming something did you then as an
adult have to figure out like that in
the studio so when you learn electronic
music and you start to blow up and
things start getting successful but the
genre also starts to grow do you start
looking around and being like holy [ __ ]
there are these kids
now that are coming up that have been
playing since they were kids that are
guy I mean if you've learned something
when you're a little kid you're gonna be
a master at it right that's why we have
that's why I have Dimock I mean it's to
foster and and support and and grow the
culture you know I mean like at first
Dimock wasn't even putting out anything
electronic
we were like rock as I was saying but in
2008 we made the shift when we put out
this group called Mastercraft and this
group called the bloody beetroots and
since then for the last 10 plus years
it's been 99% electronic do you get
pissed off when when people say that
electronic musicians and DJs don't do
anything like is it annoying you yeah it
did in the beginning but like you know
like they don't really know what's going
on so you
you know they're just ignorant you know
it just looks like nothing's happening
said sake I don't see all the work in
the studio right yeah I mean it's you
know when you're DJing you are pressing
buttons right you know it's not like
you're stringing guitar you're not you
know it's it's it's a different kind of
instrument you know you are controlling
the music but you're not necessarily
playing a guitar it's you were in bands
before you were a DJ so it's like do you
want to be like hey would you shut the
[ __ ] up I know how to play all in I know
how to play instruments yeah but either
way even if I did it it doesn't really
matter right that's not my goal up there
is to play an instrument I'm DJing so
because I know plenty of DJ's that don't
play instruments as well there are that
are extremely talented any oh yeah right
there
hello he works here at serious but every
weekend he's making towns he's doing DJs
and bar mitzvahs and weddings and
parties and and everything you can
imagine but he is like you said like he
stays so up-to-date it's almost creepy
with very current
he's very current after this past
weekend I did a wedding for an Italian
crowd and Peruvian we had more people
who worked on the staff that spoke
English as opposed to the crowd
themselves right and the these were not
Brooklyn Guido Italians these were
Italian
Italy well I could say that because I'm
a Guido Oh like that I so I had to make
sure that I downloaded all the proper
music so this crowd could react to their
music plus they also were into all the
you know it's Steve right though do you
have to look at out into the room
sometimes and figure out like how do I
get all these people engaged of course
you had to play everything I mean I was
playing you know Italian house music -
Edie em - you know pop - oldies
everything I would love to see a guy
laid any in front of your crowd because
I think they would embrace him I
actually do - I think they would I think
they would embrace Denny
very much yeah because here's the thing
about Denny he embraces who he is yeah
he wouldn't try to play up to anybody
just come on you go hello you have to
know your limitations what you can do he
always says I got to be me you know you
got to prepare so like I know it's
comics at least you said and I don't
know if you feel the same way Joe the
like when you're on stage you can
sometimes fixate on the one guy who's
not laughing typically if there's always
one who is but like you're like what the
[ __ ] is this guy's problem
sometimes I fixate on 50 to 100 people
that guys something's up with that guy
probably to make eye contact it's hard
not to look at somebody who's but you
know what's exciting is if you can get
that one guy to smile or like laugh yeah
yeah you're like it changes everything
of course yeah that's the same thing
sometimes in comedy they'll be like
they'll just one guys in every comics
like there's one [ __ ] that won't
laugh and then I come back and I'm like
he liked me it's crazy losers is that
the way I mean unless the two DJs both
of you are like you see a person you're
like that I have to get this person
engaged I think with anyone that's on a
stage you can't help but do that like if
you're an entertainer you're you want to
entertain you know so if someone's not
entertained you're like how do I it's
like a challenge you know you want to
like get this guy or girl to to like
change their mood right and I keep
checking on them like I don't I don't
want to focus I think it's really really
toxic to focus just on those people but
you know I do check in on them and
glance over but um yeah every like so
I'm like I wonder if this is gonna get
them I wonder if this is gonna get them
and if like you know like then like the
fifth the fifth moment gets them I'm
like god what's bombing for a deal if we
frosted to do that what what's bombing
for it like you mess up that bombings a
mess up right like if we're on stage and
nobody's laughing hates us so I I said
it's usually a technical issue it's a
what's called train wreck when when to
when to songs are not matched so the the
actual kicks like you usually have a
kick out to do right but if like you're
mixing the next song and if you're you
you don't time it right it's like to do
to do to do the two of the two of the
two people like whoa what's going on I
can't like use my dance moves
like this this guy sucks you know that
that happens that mean happens to me
many times I've it's not not as much
anymore but I mean I've gone through the
wringer plenty it's heavy load yeah oh
yeah for sure yeah you just have to
practice Steve that's it I've at every
situation that's bad that's happened to
me on stage I've had like I was on the
DJ booth and I'm about to jump in the
crowd and the DJ booth just collapses
and everything falls apart
the equipment's on the ground this music
stops it's like skids out and everyone's
like like they don't know about whether
to boo or to be like oh you know like
you guys pick it up in front of
everybody and plug it back in shake it
off my my stuff and I'm like uh okay let
me try to make a joke you a backup
computer with you like if you play
things on a Mac or whatever do you have
backup in case it's so I stopped I
stopped DJing with a computer because
I've had that problem a tech like you
know computer problems like I haven't
brought four computers one time to a
show for I have a tour manager that has
my my whole setup plus a backup and then
my setup and a backup and it was the
biggest festival of my career it's
called Tomorrowland in in Europe and and
for 15 minutes I could not get anything
working everything's the spinning wheel
of death on all the computers oh my god
and it was like my biggest moment I was
closing the main stage in front of
80,000 people unless the live stream is
like to millions of people and there was
a positive it was an operator error it
was a computer issue I mean just like
everything was like like you know the
gods of like death came down and said
like you this ain't gonna happen for you
I mean ventually turned on like you know
every one of them turned on what do
people do while you were standing they
all know that wait patiently yeah first
like start chanting your name because
they're excited because you're about to
go on they're like okay he's about to go
on and then five minutes they're a
little they're like okay they stopped
chanting the name and they're like
looking around then you hear some boos
then you hear it's like it just gets
worse and worse I mean you just
literally
throw up so what do you use now I just
have s DS s T is like USBs okay that's
like the the great thing for DJs is that
you don't really need to bring a guitar
with you like all use headphones and
like these you know these little drives
yeah exactly yeah and then you just plug
it they have like equipment that you
plug them into yeah so you have you have
these like they're called CDJs it's it's
funny because no one uses CDs anymore
right
but there are these machines or like
these CD players and they have a little
thumb drive insert and then and then
there's a computer kind of like a like a
screen right and then you just scroll
through like you know how all your songs
there and then then you can be able to
mix usually there's four of them you
know so that way you can have four
different setups queued up and you have
a mixer that controls all four decks
what's that I have a controller
all-in-one system by Denon I think down
DJ people want to send you everything
have you ever had any of those disasters
at like a wedding oh yeah sure yeah what
do you do because the wedding is almost
like I mean I don't know if it's worse
cuz you got all these people waiting for
you but you know the guy who paid you
mm-hmm that's just gotta be staring
daggers in here Steve is wrecking a
night you're ruining something so
special right I have one computer setup
with their song the other computer you
know with a backup right and a thumb
drive on an old digital system as well
so I have three fail-safes but what
happens when it doesn't work what's that
you got three of them I mean one of them
was gonna work yeah okay you know for
speakers I've carry more microphones and
you know I carry a lot of backup you got
a panic though when equipments not well
in front of people like I can't I've had
mics go out but again everyone knows
it's not my fault but when you're the
music person and it's just nothing's
working I said what panic you just gotta
bring some juggling balls you just talk
to them while your tech guys are working
on it yeah yeah I mean like you know try
to make a joke or to put my personality
to the test and you know now do you ever
try to do what I did you just kind of
I feel like that might be good and it
really only gets better the more you
doing have some legs to it so what do
you cover in the book besides just the
failures do you cover childhood all that
stuff oh yeah it's a childhood I cover
death and my father dying my very good
friend who's it also DJ 2009 Paso a DJ
am he passed away and talk about that I
talk about like you know I mean there's
a lot of stuff honestly for me it was
very personal on a it's almost like I
was talking to my therapist at the same
time like when as I was writing my book
I was dealing with a lot of the the
process of running away from trauma and
and I okay so I do about 250 shows a
year every single year and I've been
doing that for 12 years Jesus so for for
someone like me I literally just running
I'm like a moving train constantly going
from place to place so it's very easy
for me to just go okay I have I have an
issue I'm just gonna I'm just gonna take
off you know right that's the sanction
have to deal with anything and I can
actually move on with my life and I'm
like okay I don't really have to
confront anything so in the last the
last three years I spent six years on
this book but last three years I really
confronted and I sat with a lot of a lot
of vulnerabilities a lot of stuff that
was just sitting in my psyche I don't
know what you want to call it but and
and it helped me understand myself a lot
better it just you know I think in the
end it's it's more for me than anybody
else and and the reason why I made this
book is because I I made a documentary
with Netflix called I'll sleep when I'm
dead and is great by the way thanks for
checking out so that was a few years ago
and I it's a very personal story it's
less about the EDM culture or me as a DJ
really story about me and my dad and
then me and my mom really it's just life
it's a story of that that that I think
that a lot of other people can relate to
because we all have you know dysfunction
we might have dysfunction relations with
our family or
we want to approve ourselves sort of our
parents or whatever might be so when I
started when I saw that personal the
parallels that the other people were
getting from the doc I was like I needed
to really kind of go into my stories
deeper and talk about that are you
therapy now yeah I mean I've seen a
therapist
what guy into it was there sometimes we
just like oh I got to go to therapy
it was like one moment where you're like
I just enough relationship issues you
know like you know years back and how
did how do like you see the mediator you
need like someone to come in and be like
here's you know we deal with this all
our I deal with this all the time at the
end of day most of these things everyone
deals with everyone has very similar
issues and like here is the healthiest
way to discuss a problem oh you went to
couples now I've never done that I
probably should have it's a do you find
that they're siding against you or did
you win some of the points you clarified
you're in the wrong position already
exact it's about winning was there any
stuff that they like no you're
absolutely right yeah the therapist goes
you know Steve might be right on this
I'm eight four and one with your partner
with you yeah you have to let go of that
whole side yeah that's number one and
you have to take accountability for you
know at the end of the day she's gonna
stop blaming anyone else for your own
stuff and you got to just handle your
own I went to couples therapy once and I
knew it wasn't gonna work for us at the
time because we went in and it was what
it was you know we were talking it was
like an introductory thing but there was
some stuff that seems right on that and
there was other stuff that like oh jess
is right but like on our way out jess
was like well [ __ ] her hear what she
said about me I was like okay this isn't
weird for this out ourselves yeah I've
never done it did you go for it but you
still go yeah I see a therapist who I
just it's a
I mean it's it's I think it's good for
anyone just to kind of you know
especially like you know someone like me
that's constantly moving I need to like
you know I learned how to meditate in
the last few years like you know learn
how to stop and reset you know all those
things are really important for me I
think that's that's where this book
really thrives is in those places so
that's interesting I'll definitely by
the way I just realized ID I lied I have
got a couple therapy once the
relationship didn't last long after that
I forgot I just liked it's probably
probably the relationship didn't last
yes I was cheating and she caught me is
it tough like working especially as a
younger person working towards success
when your dad was a founder of Benihana
obviously like super successful dude and
like had a lot of you know celebrity
friends and powerful friends and
everything when you've got a father
that's that successful doing what he's
doing like it's your whole definition of
what you should be striving for skewed
yes yeah yeah so I mean when you're
growing up here's the thing they'll say
like if I grew up really under his wing
mm-hmm I would have a complete different
life but I grew up with my mom across
the country and she's you know very
traditional Japanese very humble home
like it's it was a completely different
it was like the opposite the opposite of
his life he was like okay I've landed on
American soil I gotta be an American so
I'm going to like like you know the
first time he made money he was like
okay I'm gonna buy this car I'm gonna
you know hey you know do what he what he
thinks an American does right right my
mom was just very traditional Japanese
so I would it would just be like night
and day whenever I would actually go on
these trips with him whatever wherever I
would go and and it was it was like a
superhero because like I wake up and we
were like in a middle of prairie and
like there we're in a hot-air balloon or
something like that you know or you know
doing something where we're in a
different country and I'm like wow I've
never been out and
you know Europe or wherever we are
wherever we're traveling and yeah it was
is definitely you go back into Newport
Beach and it's a completely different
kind of life so I mean it was is
interesting it was it was a unique kind
of experience but one thing that I
learned from him is that he one of the
best things that he taught me was that
he didn't actually you know I think the
idea is that when someone Falls like
with if a kid Falls and you're like okay
I got to help them pick them up if you
keep doing that they're never gonna
learn and they're never gonna learn to
pick themselves up and and quite
possibly they'll they'll just live at
home for the rest of their lives
you know right that's like a that's what
happens so a lot of kids that that get
you know but you don't really realize
that until way later right like when
it's happening that sucks right yeah so
you kind of as an adult figure out like
oh this is what made me an independent
person right right and so since my dad
he was never that kind of person to like
okay he fell I need to pick him up you
know we do I mean all of us kids we just
had to figure ourselves out and how to
get from you know just the basics on
ball so he wasn't even around right know
that that helps in that regard too so I
feel like for me that was one of the
best lessons because there was times
when I like I could have used his help
in some capacity financial or otherwise
and I had I had to figure it out
otherwise I was like like really [ __ ]
right and and you know when I started my
own business Dimock my label I was
actually signing some pretty big talent
like I was signing some really big bands
so I thought that I was crushing it
because I was like okay we just so like
80,000 EPS mm-hmm but that like then we
look in the bank and it's there's
nothing in the bank and then all my
credit cards are overdrawn and all of a
sudden I'm like literally hundred
thousand dollars in debt Wow and and my
dad who's very rich he could definitely
afford to bail me out honey I said
and in my mom like I would never ask my
mom she just like she wouldn't even
understand like like one credit card
being you know maxed out sorry
like I couldn't ask him at this point
because that by the time I was in my
mid-20s I already knew never to ask him
for money because I know we're giving it
to you and she he would never give you
would never actually I'm like even like
when I was I remember one time I gave
him a test like to ship out some
something FedEx from his house and it
went when I first started label he would
even do that it was like 20 bucks but he
was just that kind of guy he was just he
was a very tough love very varied
you know hardened Japanese kind of
businessman like that so we could talk
to you for a long time dude but the book
is out blue the colour of noise that
Steve Aoki's memoir check it out pick it
up you've also got a song I noticed the
Backstreet Boys shirt selling out with
the Backstreet Boys which i think is
amazing in 2019 steve aoki Backstreet
Boys collaboration and it's new it's not
like it's an old song that is yet so
check that out it's amazing man they're
an interesting guy we'll be right back
with I think Dennis Falcone wanted oh
sorry
you know have you ever thought of
expanding that it plugs on your name by
having something like Steve Aoki karaoke
bars oh mighty karaoke karaoke but
because I'm telling you well there was a
girl in elementary school her name was
Carrie everyone always say you should
get married to Steve Carrie that's the
way to end any after touching story
about his father started karaoke bar
that plays on your name how are you
doing radio
one more gemandsam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM app
[Music]